We just saw that if we replaced c in our original equation with c plus 4, we end
up with a simplified equation that is what I just read off. Now, I'd like to
show you how the graphs of the old equation and the new equation compare. The
first equation we had is shown by this blue curve, and the new equation is shown
by this orange yellow one. Now, the difference between these two graphs is
really that the orange one is shifted four units to the left of the blue one.
And we can see that shift written in the equation in the first version of the
new equation that we had, where we have these c plus 4s visible. However, this
form is really not very pretty, which is why we wanted to simplify it. Although
the simplified version looks better, we can't see this shift. The situation for
horizontal shifts then, seems kind of different from the vertical shifts
situation. We saw earlier that if we wanted to lower a graph, we just needed to
change this constant term, in order to change all of the vertical values. I
think we're going to need new form for the equation of a parabola, in order to
show changes in horizontal direction a little bit more clearly.